[Music]
thank you
welcome once again to I'd like to know
our Bible question and answer program
one of our favorite programs here at
Secrets unsealed and some TV I'm CA
Murray and it is my privilege my
pleasure to welcome you to our time
together I'm in the company of our
president founder and speaker Pastor
Stephen Bohr as always Pastor good to be
with you it's a pleasure to work with
you CA we praise the Lord
um we know we often say this the rumors
are true we do actually like each other
at this station we work together
television can be stressful but it is so
much easier and better when you have
people who love the Lord and who
consciously think about the feelings of
each other and that is true here Pastor
amen I have the same feeling yeah or
like a family yes indeed yes indeed now
families sometimes bump up against each
other and that happens but uh when that
happens we're quick to say I'm sorry and
press on because we are all together in
doing the work of the law and you were
part of our family also so should you
like to send in a question because
that's what we're here for to answer
your questions from the word of God if
you want to get in on the fun you can do
so by writing to TV
at some
tv.org that's TV at some
s-u-m-tv.org and we will add your
question to our pile of questions and
get to it as soon as we possibly can the
questions are mounting and we like that
we like to know that people are watching
questions are coming in from all over
the world and we are answering them by
the grace of God from the word of God we
make you that promise as always Pastor
uh if you would begin with prayer we've
got a question coming in from Benjamin
Mayo from Kenya and we'll start with
that as soon as you shall have prayed
okay let's pray
our father and our God
what a privilege it is to address you
the awesome King of the universe in
prayer thank you because you incline
your ear to hear us and now as we begin
this program
we long for the presence of the Holy
Spirit
because Holy Spirit inspired the Bible
and only he can explain it to us
so we ask that as we answer these
questions that you will give us wisdom
and knowledge and give us the words to
speak in understanding to those who are
watching the program we pray in Jesus
name amen amen and amen
as mentioned our first question comes
from Benjamin mayo or Mayo
writing to us from Kenya the Adventist
work is doing quite well in that country
uh growing growing and growing and we
are happy that um
Benjamin is watching from Kenya
I'd like to know whether the Beast and
the false prophet will start burning in
the Lake of Fire right at the second
Advent of Jesus Christ prior to the
second death and burned all the way
through the Thousand Years uh till the
thousand years are finished or what do
the
following texts imply and of course he
takes us to Revelation chapter 19 verses
17-21 and chapter 20 verses 7 through
10.
secondly the false prophet and the Beast
whom Jesus will find at his return who
will be thrown into the Lake of Fire are
they two distinct persons who will be
found alive at that moment or will it be
something figurative
so that's the answer that that the first
thing I think we need to disengage
ourselves from is uh whether the Beast
and the false prophets are actual
individuals or are they representative
of religious uh and civil systems and of
course uh of the two the second is true
they are not individuals they are
representative
um
do you want to read revel Do we want to
read Revelation 19 a little bit faster
or to give some context of what he is
talking about let me let me just follow
up on that question whether the false
prophet and the beasts are individuals
or whether they are systems the bottom
line is that in the Bible beasts
represent kingdoms or nations uh you
know you have for example Daniel chapter
7 where the lion represents Babylon the
bear medal Persia the leopard Greece the
terrible non-descript Beast represents
Rome
and so the false prophet is called the
beast that rises from the earth in
chapter 13. so the false prophet is
actually a beast and of course the Beast
is a beast
and so you're dealing the false prophet
is a beast and the the other is a beast
as well yes so they actually represent
Global Systems they represent Nations
they are not single individuals yes so
having said that let's go to well
actually
the question is based on uh Revelation
chapter 20 and verse 10. so maybe if we
can go to Revelation chapter 20 verse 10
and the issue is primarily in the King
James version
and the new King James version there's a
little added word
it's a linking verb
the the three-letter word are
let me just read verse 10 of chapter 20
the devil who deceived them this is
after the Millennium the devil who
deceived them was cast into the lake of
fire and brimstone where the Beast and
the false prophet are
that are there which is in italics means
that it's not part of the original text
right at it so so really what it's
saying is that the devil after the
Millennium who deceived them
the multitudes was cast into the lake of
fire and brimstone where the Beast and
the false prophet were cast
before the Millennium and that's where
we need to go back to chapter 19 which
is describing the second coming of
Christ
and there we're told that the Beast and
the false prophet are cast into the lake
of fire at the second coming
uh actually if you want to read verse 19
and uh verse 20.
all right verse 19 and I saw the Beast
the king of and I saw the Beast the
kings of the earth and their armies
gathered together to make war against
him who sat on the horse and against his
army
verse 20 then the Beast was captured and
with him the false prophet who worked
with him and the signs in his presence
I'm sorry ah
then the Beast was captured with him and
the false prophet who worked signs in
his presence by which he did
deceived those who received the mark of
the beast and those who worshiped him
words of His Image these two were cast
alive into the Lake of Fire Burning with
Brimstone okay just stop there uh so
when are the false prophet and the Beast
cast Into the Fire according to this
what's that the second coming because uh
verses 11 through 15 are describing the
second coming of Christ Jesus comes
sitting on a white horse he's going
coming to make war against his enemies
the armies of Heaven which are the
angels are following him he's going to
tread The Wine Press of the fearness of
fierceness of God's Wrath and then the
Beast and the false prophet are cast
Into the Fire yes
now when Jesus returns a second time
he's going to return in fire
in second Thessalonians chapter 1 and
verse 7 it says and to give you who are
troubled rest with us when the Lord
Jesus is revealed from heaven with his
mighty angels in flaming fire taking
Vengeance on those who do not know God
and on those who do not obey the gospel
of our Lord Jesus Christ so when Jesus
returns a second time uh he comes in
fire yes and the the Beast system and
the false prophet system
are are thrown into the fire
but it doesn't mean that they're going
to be burning uh throughout the course
of the entire millennium
because they're going to everyone that
belongs to these systems these systems
is going to die because Revelation 20
verse 5 says the rest of the Dead did
not live again until the Thousand Years
so the fire consumes them at the second
coming and then after the thousand years
they as with Satan are cast into the
Lake of Fire to be finally destroyed yes
uh so so the confusion is with that
little word are in the King James and
the new King James version so the way
that verse 10 should read is the devil
who deceived them was cast into the lake
of fire and brimstone where the Beast
and the false prophet had been taxed
before the Thousand Years so so that
really solves the problem that
apparently exists in this verse
all right thank you so much Benjamin for
your question uh very insightful keep on
studying the word and we appreciate
your email
okay
okay the next question
um
is by Bobby Berry
this is Bobby Berry with regards Graham
Berry well this is coming to us it looks
like from South Africa
yes it comes from South Africa yes so
praise the Lord
good day I would like to know if we plan
to have an Evangelistic Outreach at our
local estate Church on Sabbath and as
part of the Outreach
we serve hot meals too okay
I would like to know if we plan to have
evangelist Outreach at our local church
on Sabbath and as part of the Outreach
we plan to serve our hard meal to those
in need would we break the Sabbath okay
okay if
if we followed
we allow two ladies non-este members
whose normal Monday to Friday work
consists of working in the kitchen who
volunteer to go to their place of work
on Sabbath heat up the already cooked
meals
go to the Outreach to Dish up the meals
and afterwards return to the kitchen to
wash the dishes are we allowed to break
God's law
by allowing our SDA members non-esteem
members our non-sda members to do good
on the Sabbath I am having trouble
reading today I don't know if it's my
eyes or my glasses or both
um
if so should it be better to rather hold
the same Evangelistic Outreach on a
Sunday okay
probably it would be better to hold the
Evangelistic series on Sunday rather
than on the Sabbath
but we need to we need to see that in
this question it seems like they're
saying that they're going to feed the
Homeless
that that's the gist that I get from the
question because as we allow two ladies
non-sda members
whose normal Monday to Friday work
consists of working in a kitchen right
who volunteer that's key to go to their
place of work on Sabbath
so they're not really being paid for it
right heat up the already cooked meals
so the meals were already cooked go to
the Outreach to Dish up the meals and
afterwards return to the kitchen to wash
the dishes uh would that be a violation
of the Sabbath well based on the
description that is given here that the
ladies are non-advinists yes and that
they're volunteering
and that the meals were already cooked
they're only going to heat them up
I would say that it's okay to do good on
the Sabbath
yes I think this falls into that
category
um it may be a little less complex if
you did it on Sunday but if you
determined to do Evangelistic Outreach
on Sabbath on Saturday then
um this may fall into that narrow window
allowing you to do that because the the
the the goal is to is Evangelistic yes
it's Outreach and um it doesn't sound
like they could do it on Sunday because
the question says who's normal uh
working period is Monday to Friday
so unless they have access to the place
of employment on Sunday well I suppose
if they have uh access to it on Sabbath
they would have access to it on Sunday
as well perhaps I just wanted to read a
statement here from the devotional book
Ellen White devotional book my life
today uh page 231
according to the fourth Commandment the
Sabbath was dedicated to rest and
religious worship
all secular employment was to be
suspended
but Works of Mercy
and benevolence were in accordance with
the purpose of the Lord
they were not to be limited by time or
place to relieve The Afflicted to
comfort The Sorrowing
is a labor of love that does on God's
holy day
so if this is defined and it sounds like
it would be if it's defined as a work of
mercy and benevolence yes I wouldn't see
any objection to to feeding those who
are in need on the Sabbath you don't
want to let them go hungry obviously yes
yes yes we have
done prison ministry on Sabbath
afternoon we've passed out food baskets
on Sabbath afternoon
during 9 11 when the Adventist Church
was in in charge of passing out water at
the World Trade Center that was done
through the Sabbath I mean they did it
seven days a week for weeks until the
the workmen you know finished so
benevolent works I believe are in line
with and secular with the will of God
for Sabbath activity yeah you know I've
told this story before
and some people who are watching
probably are going to remember it but
when I started my Ministry in Chicago
in what was that at that time the West
Side church I got a call on Sabbath
morning from one of the elders saying
you know there's this family who's not
Adventists that don't have any money for
food and they're all you know really
hungry they have children and so I said
not a problem
um I'll take care of it so I went to the
supermarket to do some holy shopping on
the Sabbath and I had a grocery card I
filled a grocery cart with what I felt
non-advinists would enjoy eating
obviously not vegan food because they're
not evidence and so I filled my card and
I went and paid at the cash register and
on the way out a Pharisee was seeing me
coming out of the supermarket on Sabbath
with groceries
and so soon the story got all around the
church and Pastor board did his grocery
shopping on the Sabbath
and of course the story got to me last
yeah and when a member comes real
sheepishly and he says Pastor you know
there's this rumor going around that you
do your grocery shopping on Sabbath
and you know I tried to Rack my brain I
said I don't do shopping on Sabbath I
just couldn't remember because it wasn't
my routine right he says somebody saw
you such and such a Sabbath come out of
the grocery store and then it dawned on
me I said oh wow you know I did and then
I explained to him that there was this
family that was hungry they didn't have
anything to eat so I went and shopped
for food in order to feed them and he
was very embarrassed he said he said
pastor I'm really sorry and so I
announced it in the church and there
were a lot of members that were very
embarrassed by what they had done
so there is such a thing as holy
shopping on the Sabbath when it's a work
of benevolence for other people and I
think that's the principle that we need
to keep in mind indeed indeed I think
it's a good principle it's it's in line
with Christ once with people and uh well
said well done
alrighty all right what's our next
question of activities
um okay we're done with this one this
one's from Cameroon
yes this is Alexander Cassie
from duala
duala Cameron okay I like to know the
following question in the Bible Jesus
Christ is seen in the temple at age 12.
Luke 2 verse 42 and the next time that
he appeared in the Bible
uh he was a he was aged at the age of 30
uh when his when began his ministry my
question is where was he and what was he
doing between ages 12 and 30.
am I missing something in the scriptures
is there something there that he doesn't
see
well you know I will answer according to
the title of this program I'd like to
know
actually actually Ellen White does give
us uh some
details about the work of Jesus in the
carpenter shop that it was very very
perfect and meticulous yes and she says
many she he was very respectful to his
friends so Ellen White does give us some
description of what happened between 12
and 13. the word that I recall reading
from that particular passage was he made
himself subject to his parents he did
the things that a normal Jewish child
would do
um at the age of 12 or thereabouts one
flips over from uh direct teaching from
the mother to direct teaching and too
late from the dad which may occasion why
uh Mary and Joseph both thought he was
someplace else maybe he thought he would
stay with his mother she thought he had
gone to his it was with his dad but
there was a change over uh when the the
trade is taught and the the you know
household duties so he he made himself
subject like a a normal young man he
obeyed the will of his parents uh given
the fact that uh his time for for direct
Ministry had not come yet so he was a
good and dutiful son and child we don't
have the day-to-day operations but we
know that in all things he was a good
example and a good young man and
obedient to his parents well we know
that he lived a life without sin yes so
if he lived a life without sin that
would mean that he didn't sin while he
was a child either correct so he must
have been an exemplary child the kind of
child that every parent would like to
have
I am sure you know one thing I remember
I don't remember if it was story of
redemption or Desire of Ages I came with
the impression that Mary and Joseph
never had to tell him anything twice uh
you know they didn't have to drone on
about do this do that he was he
volunteered to do things he thought of
things in advance he looked at the
situation and said you know know maybe
that's why I did this for my parents it
was more of that than the thing Jesus
would you come and help me with this he
thought about that already he's ready to
help he's willing to do so yeah yeah the
interesting thing though is that he
always obeyed his Heavenly parent first
he says I I am don't you know that I was
about my father's business it was kind
of a little rebuke it was Joseph because
because they chewed him out yeah you
know for getting lost yeah
I have a responsibility to a greater
father a heavenly father
and it seems though since they didn't
have a rejoinder that they understood
that they they knew that his his primary
mission was a little bit bigger than
just being the beautiful side right
right of them so good question and thank
you Alexander
okay the next question I don't know if
we have the time to answer this question
fully but let's give it a whirl
um why is it that Pastor Bohr has a
different layout of the seven heads of
Revelation 17 or why is there a split
within the Adventist Church regarding it
the reason why is because it's
unfulfilled prophecy
and uh you know there are certain
aspects of Revelation 17 that have not
been fulfilled yet and the best we can
do is to study scripture and come up
with with the closest to the truth as
possible
um it is true uh and this uh is here
with the question that he's asking it is
true that uh I have taught that the
seven heads are Babylon the medes and
Persians Greece Pagan Rome papal Rome
the United States and then number seven
would be papal Rome restored to power
once the deadly wound is healed there
are others who say that it's Babylon
Meetup Persia Greece Pagan Rome papal
Rome France in the French Revolution
yeah and then papal Rome so there's one
difference and that is that some believe
that the six had his friend the sixth
head is France and I believe that it's
the United States and allow me to share
the reason why I I believe that the
sixth head represents the United States
each one of these was a persecuting
power
in other words while it rained it
persecuted God's faithful people and so
it has to be a it has to be a power that
persecutes God's people
um and of course the United States fits
that bill uh I want to read from Ellen
White Vol 7 of The Bible commentary page
where she is talking about Revelation 17
specifically
uh this is how it reads in the 17th of
Revelation it's foretold the destruction
of all the churches who corrupt
themselves by idolatrous Devotion to the
service of the papacy those who have
drunk of the wine of the wrath of her
fornication
and now she says thus is represented the
papal power which with all
deceivableness of unrighteousness by
outside attraction and gorgeous display
deceives all nations promising them as
did Satan our first parents all good to
those who receive its Mark in all harm
to those who will oppose its fallacies
the power which has the deepest inward
corruption will make the greatest
display and will clothe itself with the
most elaborate signs of power
the Bible plainly declares that this
covers a corrupt and deceiving
wickedness yes upon her forehead was a
name written mystery Babylon the great
the mother of harlots and Abominations
of the earth now uh it's spoken about
the papacy as the Beast yes and then the
statement ends like this what is it that
gives its Kingdom
to this power
in others what is it that gives its
Kingdom to the papacy
and Ellen White answers protestantism a
power which while professing to have the
temper and spirit of a lamb and to be
Allied to Heaven speaks with the voice
of a dragon
so this is a clear description of the
Beast that rises from the earth it says
the Beast that rises from the earth will
give its Kingdom to the papacy yes which
means that it's going to heal the
papacy's deadly wound and the papacy
then will rule as head number seven yes
so that's the reason why I believe that
the United States which is described
here as a kingdom
is the power that is going to give the
the its kingdom yes to uh the papacy
yeah France does not precisely fit that
that model uh the church did some
terrible things in France uh and and
their outstanding for the acts during
the time of the French Revolution but it
doesn't it doesn't have a a a a kingdom
to give to to the papacy and the United
States and furthermore France arose
against the nobility
and it arose against the apostate Church
it did not persecute God's people it it
raised itself against that power that
had persecuted God's people during the
1260 years yes and yet Ellen White you
know has told us there's there's still
you know right now I believe in between
head number six and head number seven
we're in the period of the deadly wound
and uh when Ella white warns us in the
book Last Day Events page 16. the
closing scenes of this Earth's history
are near at hand the unfulfilled
predictions of the Book of Revelation
are soon to be fulfilled this prophecy
is now to be studied with diligence by
the people of God and should be clearly
understood so she's saying we need to
study these prophecies even though
they're unfulfilled then she writes it
does not conceal the truth it clearly
forewarns telling us what will be in the
future speaking about the Book of
Revelation so so just because it the the
last portion is unfulfilled doesn't mean
that we should not tax our resources our
mental resources to the max yes to
understand what it's trying to teach
very good the the good thing about the
Bible all of the gold may not be lying
on the surface sometimes you got to dig
a little bit and rearrange a little bit
but the answers can be found and by the
grace of God uh when you find them they
are light onto your path and they let
you know what is coming and what is
coming soon well again we've had a a
quick 30 minutes it goes very very fast
when we get into answering your
questions we continue to solicit your
prayers and your questions our time is
fast delivered into eternity allow us in
closing to wish you both Grace and peace
through our Lord and Savior Jesus Christ
we'll see you again soon bye bye and God
bless
thank you
[Music]